demarcus williams university of georgia  t.j jackson wayne state university  tavares news king merrimack college  todd royal smoochie wallace  university miami disquarius greene jr  university of notre dame ibrahimo zeus  university of tennessee at chattanooga  jack marius tax theratrix michigan state  university the isaiah t billings club  coastal carolina university the jasper  probing crux iii  south carolina state university  leo's maxwell jillian's east carolina  university  javaris jamar javaris and lamar  university of middle tennessee devoine  shower handle  university of southern mississippi  hingle mccringleberry penn state  university